my dad's the greatest dude I ever met my
life and he had a temper anytime
anything broke in the house five minutes
into fixing it he was bitching about his
marriage was hilarious
he'd see some bronco Christ will you
look at dad
god dammit Billy give me that [ __ ]
screwdriver I swear to god I'm what the
[ __ ] I ever got married for 13 goddamn
years of this [ __ ] oh you're a [ __ ]
lady you've been a [ __ ] for years most
guys were left by now most guys would
have left by now it was one of his
catchphrases most guys would have left
by now and you don't know [ __ ] good
you got it lady
man when I was a kid I thought he was
nuts then I got older you know started
dating I realized these guys make a lot
of good points he's not expressing them
in the healthiest of ways I gotta be
honest I'm kind of I'm kind of like
jealous of the way my dad gets to talk
to my mom sometimes you know where are
all those old-school women you can just
take your day out on yeah where did they
stop making those angels who just knew
it had nothing to do with them they just
sit there and let you blow out the lines
right what a luxury right to fail all
day you come home and download all your
insecurities on this other person how
was your day out of [ __ ] was your day
how do you make a distinction I think
these kids away from me give me a
goddamn drink I'll with the tears then
the bra-burning generation came in right
now you gonna sit there and listen to
their stories all the time oh it's the
worst
you're the worst is when they're telling
you a story and you want to listen but
what they're talking about you can't
even retain it so I supposed to go out
to lunch with Jennifer I'm all ready to
do that I show up she's there with Susan
she knows I hate Susan I look like [ __ ]
Susan's been going to the gym I mean at
that point your head is like a newborn
baby you're trying to hold it up you
know you can't even if you're trying to
pay attention you kid then there you
just start staring at their mouths after
a while like I can't believe it keeps
coming out this is [ __ ] unbelievable
nice tux fading off Danny you start
thinking about your own life right when
I take Nebraska given 28 the [ __ ] is
wrong with me it's an away game hey
Alison her boys go man it goes up
alright and I ain't got [ __ ] that was a
question
all right now what do you do can't say
yes you can't say no you got to come
with something neutral hey what the [ __ ]
you gonna do hey eddo it is what it is
you put one foot from the other and
halftime adjustments I got nothing I
don't want to make my dad's out like a
psycho my my dad's the best dude I know
man but you know I understand enough you
know he's like the exact opposite of me
you know I planned out my life a little
more right that's why I never got
married never thought about getting
married he just looked horrific it
looked really difficult it looked like a
lot of them failed then if he had a kid
you have that whole weird situation all
right you got this thing that half looks
like you half looks like somebody used
to love and now I wanna slap the [ __ ]
out of right kids coming up to the
walkie like son just look to the right a
little let me just kind of cheat but Dad
I want to look at you
[Applause]
it's brutal my dad was the exact
opposite fell in love got married to
start having kids had five kids by the
time he was thirty-three preapre
pre dr. Phil preached Chicken Soup for
the holy [ __ ] I got five kids I don't
even know who I am yet to pressure of
that feeding all those kids man I'm
telling you every three four days he
would just snap just snap out of nowhere
you know can you pass the salt
oh we slam the door have the car in
third gear by the time we got it to the
end of the driveway pop pop about that
my mother would always do the exact same
[ __ ] just lock the door behind him turn
around look at the kids and just be like
hey he's just crazy he's just a crazy
person but what is wrong with him eight
hours later he show up no apology she'd
have dinner ready she messed it up and
give her a rough time Christ you cooked
that [ __ ] out of it
I don't know I think I'd be a good dad
though you know I do come back you're
back back
somebody's missing no bra what do you
mean someone's missing
looks like one of them's missing who's
missing the bass player we'll dog he got
married oh are you kidding me he got
married this last week and he just got
married
dude we lost another one how about a
moment of silence ladies and gentlemen a
moment of silence for our friend will
dog he will be missed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's only appropriate we say a few words
about well duh you want to say if you
think cuz you know well dot very
well-known well the man come on you get
you've hung out with him he was a good
guy he lives behind a lot of drunk
bottles of tequila yeah he's behind the
ability to dress himself never be able
to pick out an outfit again bro never
that's it he's married he's got he
leaves behind the ability to be himself
now he's got a life for the rest of his
life that's bad not to mention the porn
collection he gave up cuz he's that
fucile yeah Oh sushi hey dirty dirty
well done oh my god that is horrible
ah but why isn't he here I'm yeah he got
married this past week and how come he's
not here honeymoon in Aruba island
pretending to be happy happy if you were
on your honeymoon in Aruba know what
because I'd be happy as I was in Aruba
like banging chicks from Aruba that
[Applause]
come on manners marriage that bad bro
it's pretty bad bro it's like you know
nice easy like oh yeah it's pretty bad
but that's like that's like a prison but
without the sex
why do you know that even the black guys
like damn right I got a wife I think
that way I just got married because I
thought go through that charade keep
appearances that oh yeah thing you tell
ya this were a man mmm right if this
were a memoir I would tell about my wife
what a battle-axe
I mean no one's called their wife a
battle-axe since nineteen for s five
president come how do you feel about a
woman she's supposed to be my life
partner I look in the mirror the other
day and I says to her I says honey I
look in the mirror and all I see is a
fat ugly old man and I need you to give
me a compliment she says all right then
your eyesight is damn near perfect I
said you dirty dog
you dirty dog dirty dog we have fights
constantly oh you do do you know and
sometimes it bleeds over like we were
driving a car we went past a bunch of
animals there was a pig a cow I know I
admit this is a little crew you're kind
of mad at that sounds matter so I say he
said pig a cow you know horse
remind you of any relatives she says
yeah my in-laws I said you dirty dirty
dog again Wow
not until I met my wife Alice felt
incomplete now I'm finished radio show
[Applause]
take a break for justice you'll figure
something more modern and stylish then
okay my wife went into a coma
oh sorry to hear that and the doctor
said to me you won't hear this from any
1935 comic he says to me there's one way
to wake her up but it's a little
unconventional you go in there and you
have oral sex with her I said by God he
says I've seen it work I said well I'm
willing to try so I go in there I'm in
there about five minutes and I come out
I said doc she's choking
there is no sex man I had no idea that
marriage just means no sex no none none
I have friends that are thinking of
getting married and they say funny [ __ ]
like hey you know I don't know if I
could do it cuz I don't know if I could
have sex with one woman for the rest of
my life like don't worry about that [ __ ]
you're gonna have sex with zero women
for the rest of your life that's a lot
less than one one woman who the [ __ ] you
think you are where'd you get that
fantasy I'd love to have sex with one
woman for the rest of my life any one
woman big fat dead lady with a beard I'd
[ __ ] her every day
I'd be proud to have her that's not
usually my problem these days my problem
is very simple it's trying to find a
place in my house where I can masturbate
without somebody bothering me and that's
really difficult there's nowhere to go
anymore she's got her mother staying
with us two in the guest room and I'm on
the streets now I got nowhere to go like
now I know when I see a guy in the West
Side Highway jerking off in plain
daylight that's not I'm homeless yet
it's a married man right there he's got
nowhere to go [ __ ] it [ __ ] you go ahead
and look man I gotta know what am i
smilin doing
it's not fair man I'm 37 and I own my
home I should be able to just stand in
the living room how you doing honey huh
good morning but I can't I gotta hide
I'm down in the cellar by the boiler
like a troll down there just [ __ ]
miserable as [ __ ] that's what it's like
masturbation doesn't bring much joy to
guys women seem to like masturbating
they put flower petals on the pillow
they're like oh me or whatever you know
[Applause]
my guys are laying on [ __ ] now if we're
gonna have damnit
sometimes you find ecstasy but it's
followed by the deepest self hate and
depression you've ever felt it's an
amazing drop way up here to this like oh
yeah [ __ ] is wrong with me god damn it I
gotta get to work I don't have time for
this [ __ ] right now
[Applause]
but then you get married now you gotta
hide and you have to you have to hide
because when your wife catches you
masturbating that that's sad for the
whole family that's not not a good
moment in a marriage
she comes in the cellar oh my god
and then she always wants to know [ __ ]
about it always asked me stuff my wives
like well do you think about me when
you're doing that what are you [ __ ]
high why would I do that
I can think about anybody that's magical
[ __ ] what I am married to you what do
women really think their husbands are
going on my wife yeah that's [ __ ] hot
yeah you can rep at the airport you get
yelled at all that's [ __ ] high yeah
put it in the hamper not on top you
idiot oh I love when she talks like that
yeah but you know whatever we're a
family we have a kid that changes
everything that's the whole thing the
kid is everything marriage is nothing
without a kid marriage is dating it
doesn't mean [ __ ] and you don't realize
until you have a kid here's what happens
when you get married you go holy [ __ ] I
can't leave now I mean I wasn't thinking
of leaving but now I really can't leave
then you have a kid you go holy [ __ ] I
could have left
[Applause]
we could have left [ __ ] door was
right there now I can't go you go around
the country I'm trying to get as many
people as I can not to get married
promise never to get married I've been
married and I'm just trying to help okay
she's never been there you'd ever been
married
what's your name Michael Michael if you
ever think about getting married if you
everything you've met the right woman
you want to settle down change your life
you do me a favor might remember this
face
because we get very mic that's gonna be
your [ __ ] face
[Music]
he wakes up in the morning it's a truth
man who wakes up in the morning he goes
to the mirror looks at it rough
[Music]
well there's one good thing about their
I don't want to put the whole
institution down there's one good thing
there best thing about marriage is that
these are connected they don't come on
because if they did your wife would take
it as soon as you get married you're
married now you will be needing that
[Applause]
my person and refrigerator
you're going outside with your friends
you can just leave that here
oh it's too you see all these guys on
the phone going no yes
yeah listen I gotta cancel out again me
no I'm not gonna be able to go
now she won't give it to me I talk to
her all day yeah she got the spirit ooh
well she's upset I tried to I tried to
sneak out the house live this morning
and he's halfway out the driveway she
came running on the house and then to
give it to her right there on the street
okay I'll ask her hold on honey it's the
guys know they just called to say that
they're all taken there's no I just I
just gonna take mine cuz I didn't want
to stand out you know everybody taking
okay
she said no [ __ ] way yes I said no way
that dick stays here do me a favor if
you guys see me working on the yard and
stuff around the house next week you did
me a favor D let me you did me there
kill me
[Applause]